this is one of the better parts of her
job Vera baboon is meeting pilgrims from
all over the world in front of the
nativity church two years ago the
Palestinian woman became the mayor of
Bethlehem actually as I became mayor the
dusk wasn't really posited in a place
that is opposite directly to the
nativity church I change the place of
the desk to be directly opposite to the
activity it's more than beautiful it's a
as if I'm a conducting a prayer every
morning the eyes of the world will be on
Bethlehem when Pope Francis visits on
Sunday the mayor has a lot to do until
then 10,000 visitors are expected to
come here to manger square where the
Pope will hold a mess today a majority
of Bethlehem's residents are Muslims
many want the Pope to experience the
daily life of the Palestinians one lousy
at said I'm inshallah God willing this
will be a visit in the name of peace I
don't expect anything other than that he
will support peace and that the
situation here will change the wall that
we have here jalalabad addenda I don't
the Israeli West Bank barrier separates
the residents from the sacred places in
nearby Jerusalem it allows little room
for development mayor Bob Owen says
Bethlehem has the highest unemployment
rate in the West Bank she's the first
female mayor of the city I feel very
proud and responsible and I also feel
like I am continuing on the path of my
ancestors regardless of whether they
were men or women former member sue and
my villa there are always many visitors
waiting outside her office the people
face many different challenges and the
Catholic mayor wants the Pope to know
that he should see the reality he has to
see the geographical reality of the wall
and the presence of the people living
here we'll have a look that is ammonia
we have the living stones that spread
the message and the light of the star of
bethlehem the Pope will only spend seven
hours in the place where Jesus was born
there will be one mass one visit to a
refugee camp and a lunch with local
families those are his chances of
getting close to the people in the Holy
Land the mayor and the city's residents
want to make the most out of that time